[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL GRACHANIN:
Hey, everybody.
Thank you for coming out today.
My name is Daniel Grachanin,
I'm the Cloud Gaming Product
Manager.
I'm joined by Joe Holley.
JOESEPH HOLLEY: Hi, everyone.
I'm on the Cloud
Solutions Architect Team.
I head up the game
efforts there.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Today
what we want to look at
is something core to Google
Clouds culture, which
is having an open
ecosystem and open cloud
and Google being defined by some
of the best engineers in class.
We're also going to look at the
easiest solution, and the most
convenient solution--
probably for gaming-- which
is gaming analytics to
analyze telemetry, data user
profiles, whatever you need.
Now, with that there's
a lot of different ways
you can handle this.
You can use our entire stack.
You can use things from our
partners or ecosystem there.
You can use even your own
proprietary technology.
So what we've done is have our
featured partner and customer
which will come on stage
and introduce himself.
And during his
presentation, they're
going to go over how
they use our stack,
and some parts of
third party solutions,
and some proprietary solutions.
MITJA BEZENSEK: Hello, my name
is Mitja, I'm from Outfit7.
I'll be explaining how we
do data analytics in Talking
Tom and Friends mobile games.
COLIN ZIMA: Hey, everyone.
I'm Colin Zima.
I run product and analytics
at a company called Looker,
and we do a lot of
analytics on top
of all sorts of
different databases.
But a lot of really good stuff
on top of the Google Platform,
so we'll show you that in a sec.
DANIEL GRACHANIN:
Thank you, guys.
And thanks for being here.
So as I said, what
we're looking to do
is go over entire
mobile analytics stack,
and show you how you can use
it-- either in our platform,
cross functionally, from
all these different partners
and customers, and see how
they use it in real time.
Again, what's core
and fundamental to us
in game development
is game developers
want to make games and
creative experiences.
And we want to give you
fully managed solutions,
so that back-end kind
of processing you
don't have to spend so
much time working on.
It's a way to be efficient
and scale with our technology
while getting you back
to the core thing, which
is making fundamental games.
I'd like to go over some
of our strategic partner--
after this we'll
have Joe go over
some more strategic partners
we have in customers.
As well as show us
kind of the inception
of how we begin this analytic
stack for data engineer.
We'll then move on to how data
scientists, data analysts,
and business analysts
might use our entire stack.
So there'll be something for
everyone in the crowd, I hope.
JOESEPH HOLLEY: All right.
I hope this one works, great.
Thanks, everyone,
for joining us today.
Really happy to
see everybody here.
The first thing I
want to do is briefly
go over what we're
going to cover.
So there are plenty of
talks about why analytics
is important for your game.
That's not what we're
really going to cover here.
We're going to assume
that you already
are sold on the idea
of you need analytics,
and the insights are valuable.
So we're just going
to mostly talk
about actually implementing
those, and specifically
the advantages that you
can get implementing
those on Google Cloud Platform.
So currently we do have a really
large group of some very large
game companies.
We're really happy to be
working with all these folks.
Daniel and myself
are on a team that's
dedicated to just working
with game industry people.
We have a lot of
folks on our team
that come from the
industry and have
a lot of industry experience.
If any of you are
in the game industry
and you would like
to work with us,
we would be happy to have
your logo up here next time
that we give this talk.
So for those of you who are
familiar with analytics,
this is a very basic
analytics flow overview.
This is probably
really familiar.
There's four stages to every
analytics flow, ingest,
storage, analysis,
and visualization.
Starting on the left
of there, your game
is where you're
actually going to be
generating those analytic
events, your telemetry events.
You'll ingest them
generally through a gateway.
We have a lot of customers that
just do those using an HTTP
REST Endpoint.
Some of them like to use, for
example, App Engine, I think.
Later on we're going to
hear from a customer who
does it using Container Engine.
Storage obviously, we have a
really robust object storage
available, and we
actually recommend
that you go ahead and
store all of your data
directly in BigQuery.
And I'll discuss that in
more detail in a minute.
And then the analysis
portion where
you're going to have your data
scientists or engineers figure
out what the insights
are and build
some visualizations
that you can then
give to the development team.
That's mostly going to
be covered by Daniel
a little later.
This is the flow
from left to right.
Ideally, what we wanted
to get to is the flow back
from your dev team
taking those insights,
putting them into your game
to increase engagement,
make players happier
with the things
that you're doing in the
game, help you monetize.
This is a reference architecture
for Google Cloud Platform Game
Analytics.
So real-time and batch
are both supported.
For example, your
real-time events
may be coming from devices
or your game client.
Batch loading,
it's really common
to have folks send batches
of analytics events
after a match is finished
or directly from the server
that people are playing on.
For the ingest
portion of that, we
recommend that you use Google
Cloud Pub/Sub to take real-time
And if you're going
to do a batch ingest,
you can just upload the file
directly into Cloud Storage.
And we have an ETL service
that we call Cloud Dataflow.
It's capable of taking your
events both from the real-time
and the batch segments
and putting them
into BigQuery for you.
You can also
transform them if they
need to be in a different
format for the way you
want to store them in your data
warehouse or your data lake.
We do offer a data exploration
tool called Cloud Datalab.
We'll be going over that a
little bit later in the Talk.
That's really useful for your
analysts and your scientists
to quickly explore
the data, figure out
where the insights are, use
that to build the reports
that you're going to send to
your dev team or your business
analyst people.
This is the reference
architecture.
If you want to get into
that in more detail,
we do have installations
around the show called
Tree House where
you can look at this
and dig in a little bit on it.
The first part is the ingest.
As I mentioned before, your
first section of the ingest
is almost always going
to be either pulling it
in via real-time in Pub/Sub or
batch in Google Cloud Storage.
So the advantage of going
with a real-time flow, which
you can see here uses Pub/Sub
on the left, into data flow,
and then inserts from
that into BigQuery.
So you get very little latency.
We do have gaming
customers that are
able to achieve single
second latency on analytics
using this exact workflow.
You do get guaranteed
delivery with anything
that you put into Pub/Sub.
Once you've sent it to Pub/Sub
and Pub/Sub acknowledges it,
it's guaranteed that we're
going to deliver that message.
You can put extract transform
and load operations, ETL stuff,
in data flow if you need it.
If you don't want to
do any transforming,
you just want to use that
as a data runner to get
the real-time stuff from the
Pub/Sub pipeline into BigQuery,
you can also just issue
the ETL completely.
These are all fully
managed services,
so you don't have
to choose nodes,
you don't have to choose tiers.
There's nothing like that.
It scales to handle however
many requests you send to it.
On the batch side this
is as simple as it gets.
You stick a file in
Google Cloud Storage,
you load the file into BigQuery.
There's very little cost
here, very little complexity.
It's asynchronous, so
you can do it whenever
it's convenient for you.
This is really low friction.
If you don't already have a lot
of analytics event generating
code in your client yet, you can
start writing events directly
to a local log on whatever
the user's machine is,
and then just upload that
log to Google Cloud Storage
at the end of their session.
Dataflow ETL can be put
in between these two--
like we saw in the
previous slide--
if you need to
transform the data.
Actually storing the
data, the two big options
are Cloud Storage, and the
advantage of Cloud Storage
really is just how
easy it is to use
and how cost effective it is.
We do have multiple
storage classes.
If the data that you're
putting there you're
not expecting to
touch anytime soon,
you can choose one of
the storage classes
that is lower cost.
It's really easy to
integrate uploading
to Google Cloud Storage
with whatever tools
you're using now.
If you're using another
public clouds object storage,
for example,
chances are the tool
that you're using to
upload to that will also
upload to Google Cloud Storage.
If you want to set a time
to live, like an expiration,
whenever you upload
you're allowed to do that.
This is great if you
want to take away
some of the headache
of managing,
or having an admin team check
your objects every month
to see what needs to be deleted.
To keep the costs in
check, you can just
set a time that you want it
to be automatically deleted
whenever you upload it.
And obviously,
Google Cloud Storage
is a first class citizen across
the Google Cloud platform,
so all of our products hook
into it very seamlessly.
It's really easy to use.
For example, if you want
to upload from Google Cloud
Storage into BigQuery-- that
batch pipeline I was showing
earlier that was very simple--
this is how simple the
dialog box for doing that is.
All you do is choose Google
Cloud Storage, put in the URL,
tell it where you want
it to put the data--
like the name of the table--
and whether you want it to
append or overwrite that table,
or only write if there's
nothing in the table yet.
And you can have it just
automatically detect
your schema-- you can also
specify that if you like--
but it's super simple.
The other storage option,
and the one that I prefer,
and that I would
recommend you to do,
is just go ahead and store
everything in BigQuery.
The reason why primarily
is because the actual cost
is identical.
The Cloud Storage
standard cost here has
the same price per gigabyte as
just storing the data directly
in BigQuery.
It has the same TTL
support as what you
have in Google Cloud Storage.
A lot of the visualization
tools that you folks are already
going to be using, and that
are really popular in the game
industry support
BigQuery naively.
And you can directly
upload to it or stream
to it if you choose to do that.
Also if you don't touch
a table for 90 days,
we cut the price in half.
We announced that
last year at Next.
We're really excited about that.
A lot of customers
really like that feature.
Now if I can switch over
to the demo real quickly.
I'm briefly going
to go over actually
what it looks like when you're
querying the data that you
have in BigQuery.
This is mostly just to show
you the scale and the speed
that this operates at
is really impressive.
We get new customers every
day that are amazed by this.
So here we have some
manufacturer data.
Shockingly-- although we did
talk to some game companies
about it-- no one was
super excited to give us
a bunch of their
production game data
to show to you folks today,
so we manufactured some data
so that we could show you
the speed of BigQuery.
You can see these
are pretty typical
event telemetry
analytics tables.
Some of these are pretty large.
Here's what a
preview of it looks
like where it's going to have
the user and the time stamp,
and the time that they did
something, what their character
stats looked like when
they generated that event.
So you can see that
this particular table
has 98 gigabytes and
about half a billion rows.
We have another table here.
It's more of the
same kind of data--
244 gigabytes and
almost 1.3 billion rows.
Yesterday as I was
playing around with this--
trying to come up
with a demo query
that I liked that was
sort of impressive--
I ran this one kind of to
see if I could figure out
what the limitations of
the manufactured data were.
This might be somewhat amusing.
This particular one-- if we want
to open this up a little bit--
we can see here that it queried
20 gigabytes in 2.4 seconds.
This is a pretty
complicated query.
It has two sub queries.
It's doing some aggregation.
It's doing three different
levels of regular expression
extractions.
So what this has is the
number of times people
started a level, the
completed a level, and then
the completion percentage,
which is obviously
just calculated
from those two numbers.
This gives you a
pretty good idea
of what the person who
manufactured this data put in
as what they thought the
percentage of stages completion
should be is 52%, clearly.
And in stage 10, they'd had
it so that people are only
completing 23% of
the time so that it
would be good demo data.
Again, this query speed
is really the point
that I'm trying to
drive home here.
I have tried to
write a query that
would touch as much data as
possible in this data set,
and I could not generate a query
that took more than 60 seconds.
So hopefully that's
reasonably fast.
Yeah, if we can save
questions for the end.
Hopefully that's
reasonably fast.
Show you this is a
very powerful tool.
Now I'm going to have
our customer come up.
They're going to talk
about how they actually
use these tools in
production environments.
If we can switch back
to the slides, please?
MITJA BEZENSEK: Thank
you for the introduction.
Today I'm going to be
presenting with my friend,
Talking Tom here.
What do we do at Outfit7
regarding the analytics,
how does our pipeline look
like, what data do we use,
and why do we use it for?
So Talking Tom
and Friends is one
of the most recognized mobile
franchises around the world
and is the top runner on
all mobile app stores.
That includes your Google
Play Stores, Apple App Stores,
Amazon, also Microsoft
or Windows Apps Stores.
Now, how it all started?
It started in 2010 when
we released our first app.
It was simply
called Talking Tom,
and you can still download it.
It's a really fun
app to play with.
So you've got a cat.
You pet the cat.
You can talk to the
cat, and it talks back
in a really funny voice.
So it went really
viral at the time.
We didn't just sit
back and relax.
The next year, we
released a new game
called Simply
Talking Tom 2, which
enabled the player or the
user to customize Tom.
So you could buy a
fancy wardrobe for him,
like this really cool hat that
you see, or give him a toy.
Now, really for the
gaming analytics,
it started going on or
happening in 2013 when
we released our first game.
So before those were
more apps, things
like you would take
out of your pocket,
and play with for one
minute, and then put it back
in your pocket.
Now with My Talking
Tom released in 2013,
this was the first
fully fledged Tamagotchi
game, where you take care
of your cat, you feed him.
He has to take a shower
every now and then.
And if he's hungry,
he tells you.
And with that the
gaming analytics
become much more important and
much more fun to deal with.
Because with games you have
stuff like in-app purchases,
you have more
space, how to target
different ads, and all sort
of ways to do monetization.
But we didn't stop there.
During the years
we added more games
to the portfolio, more
talking characters.
And also different games
like an endless runner
called Talking Tom Goldrun
and a real-time multiplayer
game called Talking
Tom Bubble Shooter.
So the things got
more and more complex,
and also there was more
and more data to process.
What does this mean
in terms of numbers?
So we have almost six
billion downloads,
and this is still
growing till this day.
And 348 million users playing
our games each and every day.
So you can imagine how
much data we can collect
from all of those users.
So this is a number--
each and every day
a rough estimate
is we stream five billion
BigQuery rows per day.
So our processing
pipeline handles
from 30,000 BigQuery events
per second to even 100,000.
It depends on the
time of the day.
So this is different data, like
in-app purchase, advertising
data, what the user clicked.
So all different
types of events.
Now, how does it all happen?
What you see on the screen is
our data ingestion pipeline.
This uses all the components
that the guys before me
explained, like Google
Cloud Pub/Sub, Dataflow.
Before BigQuery, we were
doing game analytics,
but we did it in a
really primitive way.
We had some sharded counters
in Google Cloud Data Store.
We used to parse logs and
dump them into SQL databases,
so that really didn't scale.
Also we tried using Google
Analytics and again,
that didn't scale at our pace
and didn't provide the features
that we need.
So this is what we
came up with then.
When BigQuery came out,
this was a real lifesaver
for our Game Analytics.
On the screen-- if we go
from the right to the left--
mobile client sent
some events, and this
is received by REST API Endpoint
running on Google Container
Engine.
So that does some
basic validation
and stores the event
in Google Cloud
Pub/Sub for later processing.
And then we have a
Dataflow job on your left.
The Dataflow job takes the event
from the Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
does some extended
validation, does
some enrichment of the
events before writing those
into BigQuery.
And then in BigQuery, we
have some business analytics
to analyze that
data, and also we
have some data scientists
that also explore
all the data that we gathered.
But it's not just the client
events that we are collecting,
we are also collecting events
from our mobile back-end.
We have a back-end also
running from Google App Engine,
and we're generating events
on Google App Engine,
and sending them
into pull queues.
And then again a
Dataflow processing job
takes those events
from the pull queues
before inserting
them to BigQuery.
And again, they are available
for further analysis.
Why do we use this pipeline?
From a technical standpoint,
it's a really good pipeline.
I can tell you that from
my personal experience,
because I work with
this every day.
One thing is flexibility.
You may think there are a
lot of blocks just to get
the data inside the BigQuery.
But really this is very
flexible because we
can do upgrades for
individual components
and not affect the
other components.
So this really makes an
effective pipeline for us,
and also we can scale each and
every component separately.
For example, if
we need to do even
a stronger enrichment
in the Dataflow job,
we add more notes.
So we just scale on
the Dataflow part,
and we only pay for
that Dataflow part.
If this was one big box
and we would want to scale,
we would need to scale
the whole big box.
So that would cost more money.
And also the high
availability is really good.
So for example, if
BigQuery goes down,
the events are still stored
in Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
Now, the BigQuery doesn't go
down often, but it can happen.
This is a very good
design to avoid failures.
Because you still have events
sitting in the Google Cloud
Pub/Sub, and when BigQuery
picks back up, then also
the Dataflow job
restarts and picks
back up where it left off.
So really good pipeline.
And if you're familiar with
microservices way of designing
things, those are
all the things that
come under the hood
of mircoservices.
What do we do with this data?
I'm going to present some--
actually two
charts-- what we were
analyzing, what is our
business benefit from that.
And the first slide shows a
number of application installs
during the days.
There's no surprise.
You see the blue bar shows
how many installs were there
in a day, and you see that the
highest bars are usually-- you
can guess-- those are weekend.
So more players are engaged
during the weekends.
And the green line
shows our rank
for the app on the App Store.
So these are two charts--
one is for Talking Tom
Goldrun, and the other
is for My Talking Tom-- that's
still our flagship game.
And this is important in
mobile gaming installs
because it directly
affects our revenue.
If you want to be
successful in mobile gaming,
getting new users, getting
installs all the time
is really key to the success.
So this is very important
for the business analytics--
getting more and more installs.
And also rank on the
app store is important.
If the rank on the
app store goes down,
if not so many users
are downloading our app,
we can arrange a
marketing campaign
to acquire new players.
Without this data, this
would be very hard to do.
And also we have some
machine learning algorithms,
which decide based on
the number of installs
by region what kind
of ads to serve.
The last chart that
I'm going to explain
is from our multiplayer games.
So this shows the distribution
of matches in our multiplayer
games throughout the world.
We see the darker areas means
that in the last 24 hours
there were more
players active there.
And you can see in the
gray stacked charts
below how many players were
active in a particular part
of the day in a
specific country.
So we have Russia,
Brazil, China, and so on.
We can see how many
users were active.
But what's important
here, maybe more
than the number of
matches, is the match time.
And this is
represented by the line
that you see over the
number of players chart.
The matching time
means that if I started
playing a game against
another player,
it means how long I have to
wait for the other player
to start playing against me.
And if this time is long, it
means that user experience will
not be that good,
and of course, users
will not be using our apps.
So we want to have the
best user experience,
and we track things like
these matching times.
And it's not only the
business analysts that
are looking at these numbers.
We also have these metrics
pulled from BigQuery
to Stackdrive, and
our DevOps team
has some alerts tied
to these metrics,
like the matching time.
And if the matching
time is too high,
then they get some
alerts, and they
can check whether
the servers are OK
and if the infrastructure
is running as planned.
Now with this I will
conclude my part.
Just to summarize-- we really
think that Google's analytics
platform is really providing--
is the key to our long term
mobile success.
So with that I'm going
to turn over to Daniel.
He'll explain more about data
exploration and visualization.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL GRACHANIN:
Thanks a lot, Mitja.
As Mitja said, I am going
to go over data exploration
and visualization.
This will kind of
cover on your stack,
although it's not partially
any particular person.
But typically, this would
be your data scientists,
data analysts maybe,
your business analysts
are probably more on
the visualization side.
But this exploration side
we're going to review
is called a product we
have called Cloud Datalab.
Now, there's a lot of key
benefits to Cloud Datalab.
It's basically data
science for developers.
It's a part of the IPython
open source project,
and you can have
IPython notebooks
you host on Google Clouds
back-end f1-micro machines,
or Jupyter Notebooks.
In fact, at the end of
Mitja's presentation,
you might have seen
he had a Jupyter
Notebook for one of the
visualizations and expirations.
You can take that, put it
on one of the f1-micros,
and run it locally with the
computational power being
done by your VMs.
It's great because
it's fully integrated
with our other products.
It allows you to enter
in Python SQL JavaScript
into your back-ended
connectors to BigQuery
so you can do things like
machine learning analysis.
So you can add your aggregate
data, combine some Python,
and just do machine
learning that way.
This kind of goes over
the connectors we have--
BigQuery, Dataflow,
Datalab, Dataproc,
machine learning, and so on.
And these can be output
into visualizations,
as I said, machine learning
models, batch and streaming
pipelines, metrics and
dashboards, and ingestions
and ETLs--
whether proprietary or
done through Dataflow.
And again, what's
great about this
is it's all interconnected
through your authorization.
And you can have the ability
to use ACLs to have permissions
for how people use
that data or not,
and it's all
completely connected.
But let's actually look at this.
Oh, my demo screen is gone.
Let's take a look
what this actually
looks like if you want to
switch me over to demo.
So right here all
I'm going to do
is just go into
our Cloud console.
This isn't necessary, but
I want to at least show you
the machine it's using
which, as I said,
is just a tiny f1-micro.
I think it runs about a little
over $17 a month to run 24/7
for the entire month itself.
And we're going to
go ahead and just
connect into it through
our Cloud Shell here.
So this is pre-built
already, but all
you'd really do if you're
doing this on your own
is the command is just
Datalab basically create.
You put where the
region zone is,
and you're off and ready
to go and you're naming it.
I'm also going to
do a no user check
only because this is connected.
I made this account this morning
associated with my Google
account, so I don't want you
guys to be able to see that.
You'll see it tells me
on my bottom left pane
here to use port 8081.
Now I'll have a local
environment corrected
to my Datalab Notebook.
Now, I already have--
and you'll see this
consistency with this DataSet
we have for gaming--
the one Joe was
showing for storage
and BigQuery will be
the same DataSet I
have for this Python Notebook.
And the same one
that even Colin will
be using for Lookers
presentation,
so it's all the same DataSet.
And again, it's the
whole entire imagery
we want to show you
that you can use
with any kind of data you want
across any kind of platform.
And if you choose us, we
are happy with that as well.
For here, if you
do this yourself,
you would just create
your own folder
or create your own
notebook itself.
And you can upload it directly
from your local environment--
in my case I had
already done that.
We're going to take a
look at what it says.
So here's just a simple
little, print hello world.
But let's say you want
to do something, like,
find out insights about
daily active users.
And our data scientists,
before we give this to our data
analysts or business
analysts, we
want to figure out what's
the source of truth
of how we're going to do this.
And we want just a
little visualization, so
the engineering mindset--
we're looking for
functionality over form.
But what's great about this
is you'll see this query
I'm running-- this is connecting
back to our BigQuery back-end.
The query is already
complete by hitting run.
And I can just do a
little Matlab plot of what
this chart would look like.
OK.
So we're in trouble.
For a daily--
I kid.
But this is, of course,
the visualizations,
what they look like.
We can go here and take a look
at our trend and our users
and so forth.
And as I said, this
game needs investors.
Daily sessions, if we want to
do that, it's the same process.
We're going to take all
these select commands
and SQL like commands to come
and call directly to BigQuery.
We'll run it.
The query is already complete.
And we'll do another
plot of that.
Now, within this, you don't have
to do necessarily these plot
out graphs if you're
not familiar with it
or you just want to use your
simple BigQuery commands.
So I can do this
here, and just have
it show what would have been
in BigQuery if I want to see it
in the same dashboard in this
case for top session duration.
And it'll spit out how
this table would look like.
And there you go.
And that's really
interesting information
for, like, user acquisition
or user information.
But if we want to find some
telemetry about tweaking
for a game, seeing if
there's a difficult boss,
or if there is something we can
tweak on a level or whatever,
we'll do the same thing--
run a command right
from our environment here.
Plot it out, and we can
start having insights
with quick visualization.
Looks like boss 10, looks like
this is a Dark Souls game.
Switch back over
to presentation.
Moving over from there--
often we have quite a few
business analysts and data
analysts that want to see
the more robust visualization
platform, because it's more made
for analysis, and as I said,
function over form.
And we have this
great initiative
called Analytics 360 at Google.
We're trying to connect all
of our different platforms
we have--
YouTube Analytics,
analytics-- as Mitja said,
he was looking for a
scalable solution for that--
BigQuery, all these
different solutions,
connecting together
on one platform,
and we're accomplishing
that with Data Studio.
It's great because--
I'll show you
a demo, which we'll be able
to securely share reports.
And it gives you-- you
actually spit out reports.
So instead of sending
like an email, or a sheet,
or a Tableau, or whatever
it is-- however you
communicate-- it's all together.
You can communicate on an
authorized secure system
and share to each other on these
full reports in one platform.
It's UX/UI for data
essentially, and you can
have multiple source ingestion.
These are all the things
that it connects to.
I think most notably is MySQL.
Yes, you can connect to your
on premise MySQL environment,
and all these different products
for Google connect together.
Let's actually
take a look at what
a demo looks like for this.
Switch me over to demo?
Oh, you did,
All I did here is I went
to datastudio.google.com.
Still on the same authorization
of where I logged into.
And at the top here
we have reports,
there's some templates.
If you want to use
a template in case
you're not a great
artist, which I'm not,
and you'll see this in a second.
Or if you want to
use your own sources,
you can come down
to data sources.
And right here just
kind of gives you
a log of reports
you currently have.
Also when you sign
up for this it's
great because if you
look at the very bottom
where it says, welcome to
data studio, the actual report
itself is a tutorial as well
as an interactive report that
shows you how to
use Data Studio.
So it's pretty
innovative that way.
Let's just see how
this would be if I
were able to do this and make
a great visualization thing.
That's not me, but you
can go to data sources.
On your bottom right
here, select data sources,
and there's all those different
products we just talked about.
Now, our consistency was
this BigQuery DataSet,
so we want to show you
how you click here.
The project is called Gaming
Demo for my Cloud Project,
and we are on game_events.
In this case, if I want
to bring in events--
that table itself--
you just hit connect.
And then you have an idea what
your table will look like.
You're still able
to, if you want,
create new calculated fields.
If you want to add onto this,
or you can change the type,
aggregation, and put
description in case
you want to have notes to each
other on how you changed this.
Once that's done, you
simply create the report.
And now everything
back-ended that
was done by your
data scientists,
data engineers,
that are connected
to any of those platforms
that we went to now
has insight based off
the dimensions from that.
So this is just a bar
graph, for example,
and you can see
from the events data
table we have sessionStartTime
as our date range
demension and our
eventid as our dimension.
Now, these can all be
changed, obviously,
and you can select different
dimensional sources and style
for how it looks like.
So we're going to do a
bit of a cooking show
here and put this in
the oven and come out
with what this would look like
if we had put a lot of effort
into it.
So I have a report pre-made,
and to switch it up a little bit
and to give YouTube Gaming a
little bit of branding here.
In this case we are
saying, what if we
want to find out how our channel
did for YouTube analytics,
or the YouTube gaming channels?
Not everyone knows, but if
you go to gaming.youtube.com,
we have an entire UI
and wrapper as well as
some features for a gaming
type of video platforms.
In any case, this is all
directly from that source.
Someone's made this very
pretty demo already for us,
and it's fully interactive.
So in this case, I was
looking at my insights
from February 8th to March 7th.
Let's say I want to dial it
back and look through March 1st,
you apply it.
It's already updated
in the back-end.
It just calls to it, and
you'll have new insights
for your visualization.
And again, what's
great about this
is this report-- all I do
is share it to someone else.
If I want to share it to Joe
Holley, it might appear here.
Well, I won't put it all out.
I can hit there, share it to
him, give him edit access,
view access.
You have the same
advanced functionality
you have with Google
Driver Sheets, which
I'm sure most of you
are familiar with.
And he'll be able to have
the same interactive report
to share, as opposed to
having like a simple deck
you share, and say
this is what it looks
like with no kind of insight.
This is consistently
connected to a back-end.
So in this case,
if we're looking,
we can see that the United
States is our most views
for this particular channel.
Wisconsin is our second most,
West Virginia, and so forth.
Now, this is one of our
great visualization tools
that we are really
building a lot more
onto and more integrations.
But if you wanted
to use something
you're familiar
with, like Tableau,
we just saw Mitja mentioned
this is what he uses.
But if you want to
use something else,
we're going to have our
strategic partner come
on stage here, Colin.
He's going to show us how
he uses Looker in cohesion
with BigQuery.
COLIN ZIMA: Thank you.
If we could jump back
to the presentation.
Hopefully you guys
have taken away
a few different things from
everyone that's talked so far.
So one, all of the
Google pipelining stuff
really makes managing all
of this data a lot easier.
You really can track
everything now.
You can pipeline
things really easily.
There are managed services
that make tracking way easier
than it's ever been.
Two, it can handle really,
really large DataSets.
Where you might have thought
about metering data or having
an incrementer to
count things, now you
can put billions of
rows into a BigQuery
and get at it very easily from
a SQL runner or a BI tool.
Where Looker kind of
approaches this problem
is where lots of other
BI tools in the past
have been built around data
pipelines and databases that
were row stores, or even
columnar stores that were
a little bit less performant.
When these services
like BigQuery
came out that can separate
compute and storage--
you really can run
very enormous queries.
You can query 20
billion rows of data
and actually get
results in seconds.
And so that means that you
need different BI tools
to sit on top of these things.
Where tools in the
past might have
pulled out portions of data
or tried to aggregate data
to return analytics, now
there's just no need to do that.
Looker really
approaches this problem
from completely blowing up
the way that BI was done
and live connecting
to all of your data.
Do all this great
pipelining with Google,
and we can sit
right on top of it.
The next thing that you
should kind of take away
from all of this is there's
a lot of different ways
to do analytics on
top of your data.
There are data
scientists that want
to write raw SQL, and
script, and do machine
learning on top of things.
And they are very
non-technical people
that want to visualize data,
pull reporting, ask questions
of data without having
to understand SQL.
As you build your
tooling, you really
do want to think about balancing
all of those different users,
and we're trying to
strike a balance with all
those different things.
So a couple key
takeaways that I would
love you to remember
about Looker and just
about how we work with things.
One is that we're deeply
integrated with BigQuery
and the Google Cloud.
So you see things
like cost estimators,
and size estimators of queries--
we deeply integrate
those into the product.
Because again, when
you're building a new way
to do analytics on
top of these things
where another tool
might live connect--
if you can't get cost estimation
or these super features
like Nested Data Structures
and things like that,
you can't take advantage of
all the interesting stuff
in the database.
Secondarily, we have deep
support for everything
that Google is doing.
Google released
Spanner two weeks ago,
and that's already
supported in Looker.
As you adopt new technologies--
again, because we're
dependent on these databases
to build good stuff
and fast stuff,
we're adopting them
just as quickly.
So that's something
that's really important
to think about as you
build your analytics stack.
Second, the real
power of Looker is
we're writing raw
SQL to the database,
so we're taking
advantage of BigQuery.
But all of this is
mediated through a model
that's holding all of your
centralized definition.
For people that want to write
SQL, there's all of that power.
You can get at the raw
data, you can sculpt queries
in a very custom way.
For people that want to
point and click and use kind
of a Tableau style interface
that might not ever
want to interact with SQL,
we've got that as well.
And that's all stored
in the data model,
and we'll show you
that in a second.
And then lastly,
because we're sitting
on top of all of the data, you
can do rollups, and high level
metrics like daily active
users and things like that,
and you can get
down to row level.
Before I jump into the
demo, the last thing
is the power of
this data model lets
us bring customized
understanding
to different types of datasets.
So this is about gaming
analytics, and at some level
all the things we've
done so far are
kind of arbitrary analytics
questions-- counting users,
doing things.
The nice thing about this
model that we have in between
is that we can
actually go and create
understanding of different
types of businesses
that are immediately
installable on top of your data.
So if you're recording data
in specific types of ways,
right out of the box
we can connect and do
things like daily
active users, and things
like sessionization, and
progression analysis,
and fraud analysis.
Just remember to
record everything,
and then we'll get
into how you guys can
take advantage of that.
So if we can switch
over to demo.
First to kind of just go back
to exactly what I was saying--
we have essentially
a marketplace
of all these different types
of analytical patterns on top
of dataset.
As you're recording data,
we have different ways
to integrate analysis on top.
We have a gaming block
for gaming analytics,
and we're going to get
into that a little bit.
This is Looker, a very
typical dashboarding tool
as you'd expect.
We've built a top a
bunch of dashboards
on top of that same gaming
set that we were playing with.
Let's go take a look at
what these types of things
look like.
These are literally
just running queries
to that same BigQuery dataset.
So behind each of
these individual tiles
is a query in BigQuery.
This 52.61% completion
rate that we talked about,
we can go look at the
distribution of these things--
if the internet will come back.
For example, we can
look at the user account
at each quest level,
and we can see
that there's a lot of
people stuck at level 10.
So if I'm a gaming company,
this is really valuable for me
to understand.
As you can see this is a
fairly smooth distribution,
and that's what you get
with simulated data.
But what the beauty of this
model on top of this dataset
lets us do is we can
actually go and explore
this data more deeply-- sorry.
Frozen here.
Let's go look at
this gaming dataset,
and we'll go look at events.
So again, we're sitting on
top of the raw dataset here.
So as I add fields, we're
going to actually be
running SQL behind the scenes.
For some people, they
might be able to read
this and understand it.
For some of you
it doesn't matter,
because all we're going
to do is write queries.
But again, the power
here is that we're
taking advantage of
all the good stuff
that Google is doing
behind the scenes.
So you'll note that
we're going to process
36 gigs for this
query, and this is just
going to run in BigQuery.
And this is actually
running live in database.
So as latent as
your pipeline is--
they talked about a
one second pipeline--
we can hook up to that data and
actually query it in real-time.
Sorry.
So this took 13 seconds to
query those 36 gigs of data,
and we've got a
bunch of raw data.
What that lets us do
is actually explore
this type of data in real-time.
Let's go browse for some
stuff I made already.
But let's look at what's
happening on level 10
to see if we can actually
understand why users got
stuck there.
First, let's look
at damage rolls.
This is just a fake demo set.
We're looking at, again,
all this stuff live.
So we're querying the
database, and I just
wanted to take a look at
comparing level 9 and level 10
since we know they
look so different.
So we can actually see that
the damage distribution
looks fairly even.
And again, I'm going to
keep emphasizing this,
but this is all just running
directly in database.
So we're writing the SQL here.
The user doesn't need
to understand anything,
and this is all
mediated with the model.
If we want to actually dig in
to level 10 and what happened,
we can create these
metrics in the back-end.
And actually I
discovered this earlier,
but it looks like we
kind of arbitrarily
made the boss of level 10
substantially different
than the rest of
the other bosses.
So level 9, our boss has kind
of low armor and all this stuff,
and then suddenly our
boss gets really hard.
So again, none of this
is rocket science.
But because all of this data
is so query-able and so easily
accessible, all this stuff
comes right out of the box.
And all of this is mediated
with this data model--
sorry, I'm really
struggling here--
with this data model
that's writing raw SQL.
Again, the key takeaway here--
record everything, take
advantage of these really
heavily managed services,
and then make sure--
as you're putting
tooling on top of it--
to think about what
you want to take
advantage of in that pipeline.
Whether it's
latency, or depth of
explore ability, or
interactivity for your users,
and try to learn from models
that you've seen elsewhere.
With that I'm going to kick it
back to Daniel to close it up.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Can we switch
back to the presentation,
please?
Thanks, Colin.
And I know he wanted to say
it, so I'll say it for him.
He was using my
Windows laptop, which
he's not as familiar
with, so we forgive him.
So just to close out, I really
appreciate you all coming out.
The biggest message that
you can walk away from this
is that we have a lot of
managed solutions that
take care of your back-ends.
Whether it's analytics,
game hosting, things
we couldn't go over
in this session.
But in other sessions we
will be able to go over
fully managed
solutions that handle
your day-to-day operations,
your backend operations,
let's you get back
to being creative
and making a game, which
is what everyone wants
to do for game development.
We have a completely
open ecosystem.
We support having your own
proprietary technology,
third party partners,
whatever you'd like,
whatever makes you
most familiar to use
or engineering to make you
make the best games you can.
On the third floor, if you
go upstairs and all the way
down south, we have
a gaming booth.
And we'll have three games
that run our platform.
Most famously with
Niantic is Pokemon Go,
which we all know of,
which is a great use case.
We'll have people there
explaining how it runs and uses
their entire stack--
almost their entire stack.
We have Titanfall 2, which
uses a middleware solution
company called Multiplay.
It also has a middleware
technology on Multiplay.
And they do their game hosting
for some of their high read
cloud for our environment
for the game Titanfall 2.
You'll also be able to play it,
so it's the most biggest segue.
And then we also have one
of our strategic partners
who actually has a session
tomorrow at 3:30 that
goes over--
their partner's
called Improbable.
They have a technology
called SpatialOS,
which is a distributing
operating system that
infinitely scales and
allows for persistence
in state-less worlds that they
back-end on our technology.
And there's a game that's
built on that technology
that you'll be able to
demo and learn more about.
Colin also has a booth.
Where is it at?
COLIN ZIMA: First floor.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: First floor.
On the first floor.
Yeah, go for it.
COLIN ZIMA: We've got a
bunch of books there also.
Our founder wrote a book
about doing analytics.
So if you want a free
book, go grab it.
Sorry for forgetting the book.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Giving
away free books, folks.
So with that if you
have any questions,
we welcome it from any of us.
Please come up to the
podium and ask us,
and thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Nice Talk.
Just a quick question about
the architecture diagram
of Outfit7.
Yeah, Mitja, I guess.
I noticed the disparity
between the App Engine
and pull queue aspect
and then the Container
Engine and Pub/Sub.
I'm just wondering if you
can speak to that disparity.
Was that just the
way it evolved?
MITJA BEZENSEK: Yes, so
it evolved over time.
What I showed is the latest
iteration of our design.
At the start what we
did when BigQuery came--
when we received the event--
we did all the processing
on Google App Engine, and
also we did the insert
on Google App Engine.
From some stuff we
used Task Queues,
but that just offloaded it
to another Google App Engine
instance.
So basically it was all
App Engine at the start.
Then we evolved into--
we started using this pipeline.
Actually this is a standard
Google gaming reference
architecture.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I kind of
had a similar question,
but to drill more
into it in the sense
that you had the Task Queues
for your apps for a game engine,
and you had the API specifically
for client requests feeding
the Pub/Sub.
And I was wondering
is there or was there
the potential for a unified
approach of just writing
directly to Pub/Sub and doing
all your transformation,
and your validation,
and data flow?
Other than the issues of--
obviously you're getting some
efficiencies in micro batching,
and you didn't want to handle
security on the client-- other
than those two issues.
MITJA BEZENSEK:
Very good question.
We considered pushing all to
Pub/Sub, but at the moment
we're using cap engine standard.
And for Pub/Sub, there is only
the REST API client available,
which has a higher latency than
the GRPC client, for example.
So task queues are
really fast, so that's
why we still prefer to use
Task Queues for that example.
But yeah, we had to
write our own pool cue
source for Dataflow,
because there's no--
AUDIENCE: Or also even
replacing the API endpoint
and going direct to
Pub/Sub there too.
MITJA BEZENSEK: The API--
AUDIENCE: The client API--
the REST.
The container service one.
MITJA BEZENSEK: The
container service is just
for ingesting the client event.
So the server events are
generated by the Google App
Engine back-end and
pushed to Pub/Sub.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: About
having the API point,
you can eliminate
that if you want,
but almost every customer that
I've talked to chooses not to.
One, because you can usually
keep the costs pretty
minimal on that.
And two, because it
gives them a place
to ingest where they
can do basic validation
and make sure that people aren't
sending events from non-client,
and spamming your
analytics pipeline
or something like that.
It allows you to do a lot
of that sort of stuff.
AUDIENCE: But you could
do that in Dataflow,
as trying to get rid of--
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Yeah, you could.
AUDIENCE: Everyone is building
that custom API endpoint now.
And I understand the
core issue of not
wanting to manage security
on the client of running
the Pub/Sub, too, and
potential micro batching.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: There's some
advantages to eliminating them
earlier in the
pipeline, so that they
can't continue down and
generate more resource
usage in further products
past the ingested point.
AUDIENCE: Might you just make
that a service at some point?
Like a pre-Pub/Sub--
JOSEPH HOLLEY: I like your idea.
Come talk to us.
MITJA BEZENSEK: I mean, I
understand your question now.
Sorry, I really
didn't get it before.
But the main point
is security for me.
I wouldn't allow
our remote clients--
I wouldn't give our remote
clients our Google service
account to use--
AUDIENCE: Yeah--
MITJA BEZENSEK:
--directly Pub/Sub.
AUDIENCE: --it's still messy.
Yeah.
Thanks.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: On that
question, too, tomorrow
we can talk more after
we do some more product
announcements.
We might be able to
better address that.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Colin.
Yes, just to show there are
some very beautiful and powerful
dashboards.
I wonder if you guys built it by
yourself or use Google's tools?
COLIN ZIMA: So all of our
visualizations are homegrown.
You can actually install your
own visualizations into Looker
as desired, built in D3
JavaScript open source
libraries.
AUDIENCE: So you build using
JavaScript, or D3, or something
like this?
COLIN ZIMA: You can if you want,
and we have our own library
as well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because we are using some Kibana
on the Elastic Search Stack,
so we are trying to look
for similar Google tools,
but it seems it does not exist.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to give a sense
for the cost of some of
those BigQuery queries,
like maybe the larger ones.
Are we talking cents,
dollars, tens of dollars?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: So BigQuery
only charges for what you store
and what you actually compute.
It's hard to say for
each one of them.
AUDIENCE: So when
we query stuff,
I think the cost
comes up every time.
Just curious, roughly what
are those larger queries?
COLIN ZIMA: I believe
it's $5 a terabyte.
MITJA BEZENSEK: Yeah.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought you meant
those specific queries.
AUDIENCE: The queries
you were making,
were they cents, dollars,
hundreds of dollars?
COLIN ZIMA: $5 a terabyte
means that 30 gigs is $0.20.
AUDIENCE: I get that.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Yeah,
that's a really good point.
If any of you use that
UI, you're actually
going to get a little cost
estimator of how much it's
going to cost based on the
amount of data it's querying.
We were logged into
a Google account
and it hides that
for us by default,
and we didn't turn
it on for the demo.
That's all that is.
AUDIENCE: Other question is--
I didn't see Bigtable
mentioned anywhere.
Was that in your consideration?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: There's
case for Bigtable.
More importantly now Spanner--
that's global availability.
There's a lot of cases
that we didn't mention
within this particular pipe.
And something about
BigQuery, too,
is we have quite a few cost
control mechanisms in our ACLs,
too.
We can get very fine
grained as far as calling
if you can or can't do a
join or something like that.
So if you're worried
about someone
on your team, data scientists
running up your bill,
you can put those cost
controls in place.
So that's helpful, too.
And we also have packaging
too with BigQuery for--
if you run a lot of queries,
you can do a certain package,
or you can do it with a
typical model we have too.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: We do have
a couple of game customers
who do run analytics
load on BigQuery.
And mostly it has to
do with specific things
that they are trying to do.
For the vast majority
of customers,
we recommend BigQuery
over Bigtable
mostly just because it takes
care of all the management
part for you.
Whereas Bigtable does
actually have nodes
that you need to add in order
to meet higher IOPS thresholds,
and being able to query
it, or insert more data
into it that
requires more nodes.
So there's a management
component there.
If you're willing
to take that on,
it can be a really good
analytic solution as well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: It
also depends on use case,
because Bigtable's
read and write,
and BigQuery does not
have that functionality.
So for Bigtable-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about BigQuery.
So one of it's advantage--
DANIEL GRACHANIN: If you
can come a little closer
to the mic.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about BigQuery.
One of it's feature advantages
is its real-time ingestion.
So real-time reporting
doesn't mean just that I
can report as of this minute.
It means that it should refresh.
It should have a tool that it
refreshes every 30 seconds,
or every minute,
so I can just watch
how things are progressing.
I don't have to press refresh.
So does Visual Studio-- no--
COLIN ZIMA: Data Studio.
AUDIENCE 5: Data Studio.
Does it have a--
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Yeah,
Data Studio is going to be
authoritative the
way your back-end is,
so in that case is--
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Yeah,
our back-end in that case
was from BigQuery, or the
Dataset was from BigQuery.
So what ever is happening
on your back-end
will be mirrored in your
front-end for that case.
AUDIENCE: So you can
create a dashboard
and set it to
refresh every minute?
COLIN ZIMA: It was just a
question about live refresh.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Automatically.
Automatically.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Right.
Whenever you are
calling back to it,
it's going to be called
back to BigQuery itself.
So there's no need
to set anything
in Data Studio for that
to happen as long as it's
set within BigQuery.
Is that what your question is?
AUDIENCE: No.
That doesn't make--
COLIN ZIMA: Can the
dashboard auto refresh?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Yes.
The dashboard will auto
refresh on your reports.
AUDIENCE: As every
minute, for example?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: I don't know
about the actual time settings
for Data Studio itself.
MITJA BEZENSEK: Because I think
that here the question is more
regarding like a dashboard kind
of product, like Geckoboard.
AUDIENCE: Yes, it's not
BigQuery, it's dashboard.
Exactly.
COLIN ZIMA: For what it's
worth, you can do that in
AUDIENCE: You could do that
[? last year, ?] and actually
I checked that.
Yeah.
I have a question on that.
Do you have to create models?
Do you have to create them?
Because that is my concern.
COLIN ZIMA: Yes.
Yes.
You do have to create one.
We'll create one
automatically for you.
So all of those blocks that
I showed you are essentially
automatic data models.
So we're going to
generate an automatic data
model when you
connect, and that's
just going to let you use
every column as a field.
Kind of a trivialized
data model and you
can embellish that as desired.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Got it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about Google Data Studio.
As far as I know, it's
still in beta, right?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Yes,
it's still in beta.
Correct.
AUDIENCE: And in Europe, we
can't really play around yet.
So we can't try it out.
Any idea when it's going
to be full released?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: I don't.
And their product
manager for that--
I wouldn't want to
speak on their behalf.
If you can come see me after,
I can connect you two together.
He or she might
be here actually.
It has Cloud
functionality, obviously,
but it's an analytics product we
use to show for visualization.
Let me connect with you after
and we can talk about that.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: And
for your question,
too, if you want to talk after.
I still feel I didn't
quite address it,
so I'd like to talk
to you as well--
with Data Studio.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have one more
question, please.
Data Studio, can it
connect to other databases
that have JDBC or ODBC drivers?
DANIEL GRACHANIN: I'm not sure.
I know whatever we
have listed for MySQL
would be the most on-premise
solution you can use for that.
COLIN ZIMA: Yeah, I think it's
just MySQL and PostgreSQL.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Yeah, MySQL,
PostgreSQL, and then the rest
are all essentially
Google products.
We got 10 seconds
till we got to--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Quick question.
So let's say you're
using BigQuery
to even record events like
sales, in-app purchases, right?
Have you had any issues
with de-duplication
of events going into the query?
MITJA BEZENSEK: Excuse
me, replication?
COLIN ZIMA: De-duplication.
AUDIENCE: De-duplication.
MITJA BEZENSEK:
Oh, de-duplication.
De-duplication, part of it is
carried by the Dataflow job,
by the Pub/Sub ingestion.
So the Pub/Sub
source has a support
to de-duplicate records.
And also when you
write BigQuery--
the BigQuery streamer that's
used in Google Cloud Dataflow--
has also de-duplication
on its own.
It's not that good as
on the Pub/Sub source,
but it still gets a
lot of de-dub done.
In general, Google takes
care with their SDK
or APIs for that.
COLIN ZIMA: I'd add
that analytics tools can
add a third layer to that.
So analytics tools can do some
of that de-duplication as well.
AUDIENCE: All right.
DANIEL GRACHANIN: Pub/Sub
will take care of most it.
Yeah.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Thanks, everyone.
COLIN ZIMA: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]